[Musique]
une entrée en fanfare pour ces acteurs
plus habitué aux strass et au tapis
rouge qu'au mur bétonné des prisons
l'équipe d'un bruit de hyphen ben
youssef est venu présenter son film aux
détenus de la prison de mahdia depuis
2015 les journées cinématographiques de
carthage mettent l'accent sur leur
volonté d'élargir les frontières du
septième art au milieu carcéral une
sélection en effet dédiée aux détenus à
l'initiative du festival du ministère de
la justice et de l'organisation mondiale
contre la torture pour tarek fanny
directeur adjoint au service culturel de
la direction générale des prisons ces
rencontres entre deux mondes qui
s'opposent la prison et le monde
extérieur rv est avant tout un côté
humanisme un outil de réinsertion pour
de nombreux résidents pour qui l'accès à
la culture a toujours été perçu comme un
privilège rare expliqué de plus cette
projection est présent oui c
la septième édition
fyk le carthage raison c'est mon but
c'est d'approcher le
l'animation cinématographique en
et eu lieu avant tout on a des clopes le
cinéma dont le reste tous les bisons et
d'où le centre du riz des questions pour
les jeux et aussi on essaie de danser
club de griche il est détenu un esprit
de
les discussions 1 culturel la sueur sur
les cinémas sur les fils et ça ça peu
d'aidé surtout qu'on a pris
l'hibernation
e
d'apprendre comment il discute comment
ils partagent
les avis comment ils acceptent le
porno compte donc c'est un an de
préparation une réinsertion réalisations
culturelles dans la vie au milieu de ces
détenus rassemblés pour l'occasion
certains semblent retenir leur souffle à
30 ans ou à l'ide ne fait pas partie du
public loin des rires et des
applaudissements de ses codétenus lui
reste concentré sur sa tâche cette année
et pour la première fois il a été
derrière la caméra grâce au soutien du
personnel pénitentiaire ou à l'idée deux
de ses collègues ont pu réaliser un rêve
celui de réaliser leur premier court
métrage un regard sur leur quotidien
morose que
j'essaie dans les maisons l'histoire a
commencé quand on nous a proposé de
réaliser la bande annonce des jcc dans
les prisons de là nous avons pris
l'initiative de proposer la réalisation
d'un court métrage je la vision des
débuts
notre quotidien nous inspirer beaucoup
de détails de notre expérience nous ont
permis de composer et on s'est servi
également d'anecdotes et de galère
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment vécu cette aventure comme
une thérapie
l'occasion d'oublier la promiscuité le
stress l'enfermement et la solitude je
n'aurais jamais imaginé que la prison me
permettrait de renouer avec ma passion
du cinéma et de réaliser un rêve
d'enfant
[Musique]
un projet entre quatre murs pour ce
jeune cinéphile incarcéré depuis six ans
pour qui le cinéma a marqué un tournant
une thérapie comédie qui sonne à la fois
comme un exutoire est comme une seconde
chance un réalisateur plein d'espoir qui
aimeraient faire valoir ses mairies lors
de la cérémonie de clôture des jcc
devant la grande famille du cinéma qu'il
entend bien rejoindre un jour
je ne réalise toujours pas ce qui se
passe mon court métrage diffusé aux jcc
je ne comprends pas c'est un jeu
trop de sentiments qui s'entremêlent
entre excitation peur et joie la joie
d'avoir à faire un pas de plus vers la
vocation pas comme une porte qui s'ouvre
une très forte vers un nouveau monde
vers leur changement un changement là
d'état pour cette nouvelle édition les
organisateurs des jcc espère inviter
près de 12 me détenus à travers tout le
pays pour une parenthèse culturelle
l'occasion pour ces hommes et ces femmes
de s'évader le temps d'une projection